how can you tell if the person you're in
a romantic relationship with is the
right person to spend the rest of your
life with you can't you actually decide
that rather than discovering it I might
suggest what you might look for on the
way to making that decision all things
considered a certain amount of
similarity on the personality Dimensions
between the two of you is probably to be
recommended you have to understand that
the best relationships are predicated on
traction trust and negotiation and it's
constant you're constantly negotiating
to to maintain the relationship to
expand it and you don't find the right
person and live happily ever after life
is far too complicated for that